foreign School leaders are on a charm
offensive the military appointed prime
minister visited Chad in an effort to
push back against mounting International
pressure
we are undergoing a transition we have
explained our reasons for this and we
have reiterated that we will remain open
to any exchanges with all involved
parties but at the same time insisting
on the necessary independence of our
country his visit comes as a country
soldiers suffer heavy losses in attacks
by armed groups operating in the Sahara
region on Tuesday 17 soldiers were
killed near the border with Mali this is
the fifth attack since the coup in the
Army three weeks ago it appears armed
groups in the region are looking to
explore the political uncertainty in
Asia and it doesn't help with
International Partners suspending
military and security cooperation in
response to the coup analysts say the
threat of more attacks like this
is increasing by the day
although the regional bug Echoes shows
signs of continuing with diplomatic
efforts to resolve the political crisis
it maintains that military action is
still possible the cool and the
political upheaval that we see in Miami
is a good news for jihadist insurgents
um for several reasons the first one is
that military leadership are busy trying
to consolidate power in Miami and
perhaps to plan any post in case of an
eventual attack by Air Force forces
just like in Mali and Burkina Faso
Nigeria's cool leaders cite the
deteriorating security as reason for
overthrowing president Muhammad bazoom
but the speed of attacks and their
failure to contain them are also raising
questions about their ability to do
something different and sustain public
support for their cool
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera Nigeria